[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'on
envies de lecture nathalie wolf
bonjour alors va essayer de donner des
conseils tous ceux qui se disent qu'est
ce que je pourrais acheter qu'est ce que
je pourrais offrir pour noël
là on va on va revenir peut-être bas
dans des livres qui ont passionné
nos deux invités je voulais présent de
joëlle goron bonjour jean patrice de
gens tout le monde
alors vous êtes vous êtes journaliste
vous êtes écrivain vous êtes scénariste
dans vos scénarios souvient peut-être de
la fameuse série des petits bouts
d'après roger martin du gard et des
passes qui d'après georges duhamel et
jusque qu'est ce qu'on va faire de toi
qui est l adaptation du livre de michel
drucker vous avez quand même ils sont
humains et puis vous avez réalisé aussi
un film qui s'appelait entre mère et
fille alors il se trouve que vous êtes
en train de déménager je vais pas de
livrer de secret mais vous allez elle
venir vivre dans les yvelines dans une
ville qui était celle d'un grand
écrivain ne dira pas égal comme ça on va
garder votre votre secret et vous êtes
en train de déménager votre bibliothèque
de la rangée est passionnant c'est
passionnant parce que on fait le tri on
regarde et on se dit pas mais j'avais
sao mai j'avais ça est en fait tout d'un
coup ça devient une illumination
vous réalisez qu'elle lectrices vous
êtes c'est à dire que moi j'en fait
toute ma vie j'ai quand même lui les
américains les anglais tout parce que la
littérature ça a été ma passion mais en
fait c'est le 19e siècle français avec
en particulier les correspondances et
les journaux intimes c'est très bizarre
parce que ça fait un peu monomaniaque
je me suis dit mais c'est incroyable
tous ces gens dont j'ai lu les journaux
intimes et les correspondances c'est pas
quelque chose qui passionne les gens en
général et là j'ai eu une idée
j'étais ans donc c'est ya pratiquement
un an et demi j'étais je venais de
recevoir la correspondance de
d'alexandre dumas avec georges soros et
puis je me suis dit oh c'est drôle parce
que j'ai une grande passion pour george
sand si drôle et ya un journal intime le
journal de la croix qui se passe à peu
près à ce moment là vient le journal des
goncourt que j'avais lu mais il ya vingt
ans et je me suis dit je vais te conduis
date
c'était jeudi 1840 à peu près je me suis
aperçu que tous ces gens là à ce moment
là faisait partie carrément du même clan
alors c'est qu'ils se voyaient y dîner
ensemble 800 violet il allait voir les
mêmes spectacles et tout est à partir de
cette date là chaque matin je prenais
jour après jour
qu'est ce qui s'était passé qu'est ce
qui s'était dit heureux je vous arrête
une seconde joie là on va en parler tout
de suite mais je présente quand même à
ce rite varennes qui est avec les pavés
côté qui est étudiante à l'université de
versailles saint quentin qui même en
train de passer des examens donc c'est
formidable de sa part d'être venu avec
nous qui va aussi nous conseillez
délivre les livres qu'elle a aimé alors
on va pouvoir commencer par vous joël
donc oui ça c'est fox est scellé
formidable de regarder ce que les ce que
les gens disent d'une même date au même
moment quoi vivre des uns des autres
oui c'est très étonnant alors il ya des
est donc trois ouvrages coucou faut que
vous conseillez qu'on pût qu'on peut
qu'on peut donc il ya ce journal de
delacroix alors de la croix models comme
celles pop savait pas qu'il avait écrit
à mais il a écrit que j'étais un homme
c'était vraiment un humanisme c'est à
dire qu'il était passionné des as
il était passionné de tout de politique
de il était un observateur de sa société
et c'est vrai que sa correspondance en
particulier avec george sand est
formidable parce que elle elle est
beaucoup plus dans le quotidien aller
plus dans le dans le dans le tous les
jours et lui il discutait et surtout
dans son journal il a des points de vues
raconte sur son travail c'est absolument
passionnant
alors c'est une lecture peut-être un peu
plus difficile parce que le journal il
est vraiment sur les armes
c'est vraiment ça alors que
george sand dans sa correspondance et
quelqu'un d'abord elle était c'est une
femme dont je n'aime pas spécialement ce
qu'est ce qu'on apprend à l'école c'est
à dire la petite fadette de la mare au
diable qui sont des choses que j'aime
pas beaucoup mais en revanche histoire
d'une vie formidable et cette femme
était passionné de géologie de jardinage
de cuisine de politique de prix
c'est un esprit universel et quotidien
c'est à dire une façon de voir les
choses par le petit bout mais qui est
toujours d'une justesse incroyable et si
grands esprits qui correspond d'entre
eux qui changeait tous et d'une richesse
formidable et je vous parle pas du
journal des goncourt qui est une pure
merveille qu'on a tendance à penser
comme quelque chose d'un peu poussiéreux
mais pas du tout
c'était des gens extrêmement drôle
extrêmement ouvert à toutes les
nouvelles choses alors en pleine pardon
pas triché oui je vous interromps parce
que justement il ya une biographie qui
sort des goncourt qui dit tout à fait le
contraire que d'abord il vivait il
vivait tous les deux ensemble ils
partageaient la même femme à sa pendante
il avait la même femme tous les deux oui
il ya des moments où ils ont la même
maîtresse parce qu'ils n'ont jamais eue
femme était beaucoup trop lié à ravard
des femmes la maison mais dit que
c'était très très conservateurs qu'ils
aimaient pas mal et c'est un peu le
contraire de ce que vous dites dans
cette biographie mais ses disciples et
dès qu'on peut alors dans cette
biographie ont dit qu'ils étaient
d'extrême droite
ouais je pense qu'il faut pas les
réduire
il surtout pas à ça c'était des gens
d'un esprit féroce et qui était très
lucide sur leur époque
voyez très bien et ont su ils ont été
les premiers à s'intéresser à travers le
roman à s'intéresser à ce qu'on appelle
à où la classe populaire ce qui a repris
zola il faut voir le lien par exemple
entre les farc en cours
isola c'est absolument sidérant de
s'apercevoir même on le voit dans le
carnet
les carnets aulas il a repris des choses
des premiers romans des frères goncourt
c'est un mouvement littéraire
comment dire souterrain qui est
absolument prodigieux c'est prodigieux
de richesses et de drôlerie ça il faut
le dire les fargo cours sans arrêt on
rit parce que entre le leurs anecdotes
du privé qu'ils racontent qu'ils sont
évidemment amusant le fait qu'ils aient
la même maîtresse et des choses comme ça
mais ils sont
ils se fréquentent si avec flaubert donc
les les dîners ou qu'ils ont tous les
quinze jours
ces gens là qui sont réunis le lendemain
ils écrivent qu'est ce qu'ils ont vu
qu'est ce qu'ils se sont dit quel était
leur point de vue ils ont menti un peu
ils ont fait un peu leur malin tout ça
c'est formidable c'est drôle et c'est
les fermes ont cours en plus ce sont des
esprits d'avant garde sa dérive était
pas par exemple il se dépassionner
peinture c'est les premiers qui se sont
passionnés pour toute la peinture
japonaise qui va venir après avec les
impressionnistes il était ouvert à tous
et des esprits lumineux est drôle c'est
ça surtout qu'ils me we qui me plaît ce
mélange comme ça de d'esprit d'avant
garde et et de lucidité d'humour voilà
alors voilà un magnifique cadeau que
vous pouvez faire pour noël si vous
n'avez pas d'idée c'est le journal de la
croix la correspondance de genre le sang
et d'alexandre dumas et le journal des
goncourt est conquis et chez bouquins on
les voit là c'est pas très cher j'ai
vraiment un cadeau formidable on les
voit à l'image on va passer astrid
nathalie un oui astrid alors on va vous
écoutez je vous présentais d'abord un
livre de rachel carson printemps
silencieux
oui c'est un livre que j'ai eu
l'occasion de le lire pour or de droit
de l'environnement le livre printemps
silencieux de rachel carson qui est un
ouvrage qui a été écrit en 1962 et qui a
été réédité par white project
il a été écrit par une biologiste marine
américaine qui souhaitait avertir la
population sur les dangers les dangers
des pesticides nativement à utiliser
donc comme une bonne scientifique elle a
commencé par faire constat du changement
biodiversité
dans certaines zones et elle va
immédiatement faire le lien entre
utilisation à outrance et la dégradation
de l'environnement et à la santé de la
population également
elle décide d'écrire cet ouvrage qui
n'aime en guise d' alerte face à une
société dont la prise de conscience
écologique n'est pas encore très avancés
mais a contrario dont la vente de
question est de plus en plus grande
ce qui intéresse encore comment une
préface de al gore et ce qui est
intéressant dans cet ouvrage qui est une
source riche d'informations précises et
concrètes également c'est qu'il a eu un
impact considérable lors de sa parution
puisque sur la population d'une part
puisqu'il est vendu à plus de 2 millions
d'exemplaires et d'autres pas sur la
politique de l'époque puisque il a
participé à l'émergence du mouvement
écologiste
il a notamment permis l'interdiction de
certains produits chimiques il était
considéré comme tron aussi donc les
industriels d'ailleurs à ce titre
industriels du secteur se sont révoltés
comme la société monsanto qui avait
rapidement réagi en attaquant
personnellement à l'auteur donc ce livre
et a réellement eu un impact fort et
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'invite tout le monde à venir et de
manière plus générale pour ceux qui se
sentent déjà concernés par les
problématiques environnementales ou à
ceux qui veulent se renseigner sur les
problématiques dans le cas molins
donc là on est passé du xixème au xxième
siècle il ya un autre livre de vouziers
par des kékés pas si calme
oui appel si keynes et un autre livre le
deuxième livre que j'ai choisi de vous
parler
il a été écrit par elena smith et c'est
un ouvrage plus ancien puisqu'il date de
1930 ville été réédité cette année par
la maison d'édition hier son récit
repose sur le journal écrit par une
ambulance terre anglaise
en fonction pendant la première guerre
mondiale winifred contentions qui va
retracer son quotidien au milieu et
c'est qu'elle est de la mort
omniprésente
donc c'est un livre qui qui lors de sa
première parution a beaucoup fait parler
de lui car il se présentait comme une
réponse à l ouvrage
à l'ouest rien de nouveau eric en
indiquant bien que tout n'était pas si
captain sur la faune comme comme
l'indiquent le choix du titre alors tout
au long de cet ouvrage
on va suivre le parcours de cette jeune
femme qui est née dans une famille
plutôt aisée et qui au moment de la
guerre on va se trouver affectée à ce
poste l'ambulancière et elana smith va
faire une description qui semble tout à
fait réaliste de ce qu'ont pu
représenter
c'est à méliès en suivant les ressentis
les impressions et les réalités du
métier de cette femme anglaise mais des
collègues donc surnommés les héroïnes
anglaise alors l'ambulancière aubin père
particulièrement part de son dégoût de
la fracture entre la réalité quelle
ville et de l'image qu'elle représente
pour ceux restés chez eux notamment sa
famille qui est assez fier d'avoir ses
trois enfants participant à cette guerre
laissant réellement mesurer les
conditions de vie dans lesquelles ces
enfants son projet google va notamment
parlé de manière crue du fait de
nourriture du nettoyage
les ambulances dans lesquels fabrice da
des auteurs macabre et j'en passe donc
c'est un livre très humain qui est assez
court et qui suis vraiment très bien qui
de manière romancée une plonge dans ses
amis hier alors que cette fois ni du
côté des politiques
du côté des compagnons
c'est qu'ils vont tout autant le vrai
lit fourvière
voilà des choix différents os entre vos
deux juste une dernière question joël
quand vous faites avec votre
bibliothèque vous allez vous donner des
livres vous au reportage de vous je
lègue un héritage à ma fille en faisant
justement là aussi un autre très
intéressant c'est à dire en me disant
est ce que l aile valley ça parce que en
fait beaucoup d'auteurs que j'ai aimé à
un certain moment il ya 20 ans ou 30 ans
aujourd'hui je dirais ils passent pas la
frontière de l'âge c'est c'est terrible
à dire et où je me dis par exemple
quelqu'un comme françois nourissier dont
j'ai beaucoup aimé l'oeuvre je me suis
posé des questions je me suis dit est ce
que vraiment elle va lire ça aujourd'hui
voilà c'est une c'est drôle de la barre
ce regard là vous nous donnerez la
réponse dans quelques heures dans
quelques mois merci merci beaucoup je
mets de remercier une fois cette valeur
bravo pour le livre de la jeune femme
dont je ne sais pas le nom voilà parce
que je trouve qu'elle a très bien
exprimer ce que c'est qu'un journal la
version que ça donne des choses et leur
garde particulier la forte sur un moment
où ou sur des gens voilà je vous
remercie
merci tout les deux juste note nathalie
vous voyez juste en une seconde
recommander un livre geoffrey la
pression fond d'accord ok merci merci
beaucoup à la voilà ben j'espère qu'on
vous a aidé si vous avez manqué d'idées
pour offrir rien que livre bon dans les
fêtes à la fin grâce à un jeu à deux
gourous et astrid bard est merci à
toutes les deux merci notre liberté
merci
[Musique]